hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm jerry
anonymous Aaron Aaron that's her name
yeah so today we're gonna check okay
first off I want to say most people
requested Star Wars Battlefront gameplay
trailer yeah I put up a gameplay trailer
reaction we're doing wrong when I did
the wrong one apparently it was the hot
one yeah so let's just watch this you
Pete bucks
Lona just get mad at me all you guys do
the right segment of the hour-long keno
press-conference promarker everyday
entertainment needs to be read this is
cool I like does not want to give this
up
first our whiskey that looks like a very
terrestrial behind
what
the bass
Wow
Hey
cool details huh
to the effects look a little better than
the movies these rebels have activated
the athlete
whoa
Vietnamese fighters video
the smart Raju the bomber can't help us
unless we protect the appointees no no
sir huh no motive Emma looks like cuzzy
tonight tavarov awajum look like it was
around in World War
but it's a 60
well these are more like the old-school
Star Wars notes whatever
the rebels have activated the uplink
station we must shut it down you can
play anywhere this column
like
Wow
fifteen
this is bridge wells examining which is
so cool you can plans all these
different types of
when you're playing this
from position to position
hell
Imperial Walker has been taken out
Walker down
so cool your place like every community
fifteen
Wow
you experience all kind of power
they show us
ts freedom
Wow stuff like that was just boundaries
and they're all names are always read oh
uh oh so there is some Vader whoa you're
wrapping a turtleneck
let's return can I throw the neck
exposed take it out you can play it yet
I do see that I saw I've been watching
it
that looks [ __ ] agree I mean [ __ ]
sweet man I mean like you know I'm I'm
not like a uh I'm not a huge Star Wars
guy like I don't love Star Wars but that
does look look cool yeah yeah yeah I
come to a lot on the other gameplay
trailer but I didn't realize you'd be
able to switch like not switch but as on
the moil is different yeah you can play
as all these different types of
characters the TIE fighter the Imperial
walkers you play as a Jedi it seems like
a ballad my turn oh man awesome that is
so cool they're allowing you to do that
well it seems like it behooves you in a
Star Wars game to take advantage of
everything because people are gonna want
to be inside of all those different
ships and beings yeah and like be able
to play as different races of people's
stuff cuz normally it's like that just a
protagonist or two yeah Aaron your
thoughts uh well I'm gonna I'm gonna
like [ __ ] all over whatever goodwill
I've built up on this channel but like
I'm not a Star Wars guy I don't even
really like it at all but I think like
if you're gonna don't like a man
you know like six years of film school
will do that to you you'll grow to hate
Star Wars if you're a guy like me but I
mean I think if you're gonna do
something with the Star Wars franchise
like a video game that gives you the
options to just kind of have all those
different systemic experiences is it's a
good way to go I'm just imagining like
what is around actually gonna play like
cuz I can imagine like I don't know like
eleven people on each team like just
being really disappointed at the end of
the round because only two guys at the
very end got to play as Luke and invader
dude who gets you gonna like draw straws
yeah I mean like if it's just like a
random thing works like oh yeah you know
I got to drive a TIE fighter and [ __ ]
and that was fun but it's like oh I
never get to be Lugar I never get to be
Vader I can imagine that becoming super
aggravating well Aaron you have lost
credibility especially in our personal
friendship Department if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you could check out reasons
to Jerry playlist on this channel of his
movie reviews and on this channel dank
ass those featuring Aaron and Jerry for
some cool movie talk on podcast and [ __ ]
you've also Facebook answer
I'm Twitter and vine we're freakin
enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as iPads iPads
are great you know if you're ever
waiting on a car doors video the great
thing about iPads is you could be
waiting in a car for like your mom to
show up grandma
sister girlfriend whatever and then you
could get bored you could get bored and
then you could go online and you know go
on some porn and then jerk off while you
wait for them oh this one doesn't have
3g though I'd be a horrible [ __ ] thing
to do when you're waiting to pick up
anybody
I [ __ ] hate your iPad just in a car
parts and publishers in turbulent with
the [ __ ]